[Music]
all right here we go no more vaccine
mandates
that are put in place around the country
one former obama official taking it a
step further right
while flying she says vaccinated people
should no longer carry the burden for
unvaccinated people a no-fly list
for unvaccinated adults is an obvious
step the federal government should take
close quote really
but in a new op-ed our next guest calls
to choose freedom over mandates
lockdowns and petty tyrants
gop senator rand paul joins us now he
sits on the
senate help committee and he also takes
on anthony fauci because no one else
will
senator what is your what's your take on
this suggestion in the atlantic
uh obscene you know that if we now
disagree in our personal medical
decisions with the left
they're going to declare that we're a
terrorist and then we can't fly
but even on the practicality of it even
if you said okay we're going to do this
even the cdc says you're not supposed to
get vaccinated if you've been infected
within three months
so we're going to do tell people they
can't fly for three months even
according to the cdc
i and other doctors actually think that
your immunity from being infected is
going to last a lot longer
with the 2004 epidemic people still have
immunity
spanish flu there are people alive who
still have immunity from 1918
so i do believe natural immunity should
be taken into account but even according
to the cdc
this idiot would have us not flying for
three months so it makes no sense
it's it's complete collectivism and all
of these people are the same people who
hooted and hollered and said
trump is leading us to authoritarianism
what could be more authoritarian than a
no-fly list for people who disagree with
you
what about the the vilification of
people that want a choice like governor
desantis governor abbott we're not going
to make mass mandates
it's how the president's going after the
governors and the only vaccinated why
does he need to make an enemy of people
well i think that if you look
objectively at mass mandates whether
it's in states cities counties or
countries
there's no correlation between a mass
mandate and reduction
and incidence of the disease in fact
it's the opposite the more mandates we
got the more of the disease we got
i don't think the mass caused the
disease but i don't think the mask
helped any
and in fact most people are wearing
cloth masks and 97
of virus-sized particles go through
cloth mask so it's actually a disservice
when dr fauci says
oh the mask is more important than the
vaccine that's malpractice the vaccine
is very important
so's natural immunity but the cloth mass
don't stop the disease and if you're
telling someone
who's taking care of a coveted patient
like it's an elderly couple
and you're taking care of your husband
or wife and have covid and you're
wearing a cloth mask
that's terrible advice that's advice
that'll kill you so dr
fauci needs to be away from government
away from advice
because almost all of his advice has
been wrong-headed but some of it's
actually very dangerous
senator and they can't handle you
because you're a doctor uh the other
thing is dr fauci is totally
uh hamstrung because of his role with
peter dadsink and the origins of this
virus which is for another time
so covet 19 cases and children are
surging for 84
that according to the academy of
pediatrics
they reported that on wednesday they did
a study and they said that those numbers
are going
up does that concern you the largest
study of the delta variant was in
england a couple weeks ago and they're a
few weeks ahead of us
and they showed zero deaths in
vaccinated people under 50
and they showed 0.808 deaths
in under 50 unvaccinated that's about
what we're getting
for vaccinated here in our country so
even the unvaccinated did pretty well
with the delta variant
it's very transmissible people are going
to get it people have been vaccinated
people who have already had the disease
are going to get the delta variant
maybe again but the good news is while
it's very transmissible it's much less
deadly
and senator if you are telling me to get
vaccinated saying i'm the problem or
you're the problem or the person
watching is the problem
how can you do that and leave the
southern border open
to 10 to 1.1 plus million people
since you took office many of which has
positive covenant 19
you're totally compromised yes it's just
pure hypocrisy
they're seeding people they're taking
kids from down at the border who may
have it
and they're plucking them up and putting
them all over the united states as if
they're wishing to seed the country with
a new variant
it's an awful thing to do but the bottom
line is for those who are saying
i won't go to a restaurant unless we
force everybody to be vaccinated
if you're vaccinated you are
overwhelmingly safe from hospitalization
and death
mind your own business i hear you and i
agree
uh senator rand paul thanks so much
thank you